montiert willkommen beim ein video
ich muss ein bisschen weiter sprechen
glaube ich heute ist egal
aber wir sind ja neuen wohnungen und
schweißen für die nachbarn
deswegen bin ich mal freuen uns dass sie
gefällt hat das habe ich dafür nie weg
auf jeden fall habe ich mir heute mal
wieder was ganz besonderes aber nicht
erst muss ich sagen das ist nicht mein
gerät
solche videos gibt auch nüsse zum fkn
deuten wir gebrauchen das ist noch nicht
alles gewinnen aber tanzen und
kritischen chinesischen japanischen
china gibt kein youtube wieder negativ
gesperrt wird und verfügt auf jeden fall
ihr privatleben
eine anders durch das ist nicht nur
irgendein anderer sondern eine riesen
anna hat wartet auf die österreicher
aber ich habe zumindest gefragt unter
anderem ja okay war jetzt hier
wahrscheinlich schon gesehen ich habe
jeden tag um ihn herum gemacht und jetzt
denkt ihr und wahrscheinlich hat er vor
dem ende machte daheim bin und ich kann
euch sagen das macht sinn denn wir
machen heute wie man überhaupt alle was
auf nicht vielleicht von unten rein
stecken oder 130 auf jeden fall machen
wir diese arbeit auch in dem wir ganz
viele gummibänder um machen und wenn das
richtig berechnet hat muss irgendwann
einfach aufhören ablassen entweder einen
platz genau zwei helfen oder obere
hälfte gegen die decke fnp
hier haben wir auf jeden fall sehr viele
gummibänder hat keinen plan aber es
müssten
ich bin mir nicht sicher wie viele das
sind aber auf jeden fall mehrere hundert
kommentare funktioniert und ich würde
ganz so lange lagern gelaufen sei
kommentar mit welcher fruchtig und auch
du kannst eigentlich haben wir relativ
viel länger
leute ich freue mich deshalb nicht so
viele kaufen gibt es schon mal sagen
noch fand nicht im klassischen werde
haben wir überprüft locker gedachte
müssen mindestens 300 gummiwerk
[Musik]
explodiert die eigentlich ganz schön
aber nicht das eine ist ein bisschen die
luft
da brauche ich nehme jetzt versteckt
oder so macht die einfach etwas 14 stück
oder keine ahnung wie viele 23 davon
[Musik]
mindestens 200 gummibändern aber wir
haben ja auch eine menge und nach vorne
man passiert ist
[Applaus]
[Musik]
und heute kann am besten jetzt nötig
hätte ich gedacht dass lukoil klar weil
eine harte schale und läutet bitte diese
kommentare spiel okay keine angst wieder
fertig aufgegessen auch ein bisschen
kraft raubt mir gesagt hey alter wie das
geschnetzelte flecke auf jeden fall in
die kommentare
mit welcher absicht noch am ball und
lassen nach oben dann in die box ab und
fand ich echt witzig und hat wieder
recht extrem spaß weil man einfach nicht
weiß lackierten billionen dollar wieder
auf 17 uhr denkmal für nicht warum ist
für donnerstag sind sie weniger
einrichten und es wird einfach nur geil
wird von rüdiger r und mit einer mehr
zufrieden mit der wohnung im landratsamt
wieder einmal kurz den flug auf jeden
fall am künftigen zeitnah im zentrum
wenn er mich von 1500 megawatt erreicht
ich hoffe er auf mich so auf eine andere
website twitter habe ich mich kraftlos